>> Greg: SPECIAL
>> Greg: "PECIAL
>> Greg: "SPCIAL
>> Greg: "SPECAL
>> Greg: "SPECIAL
REPORT" WITH BRET BAIER IS UP
NEXT.
HEY, BRET.
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING, I'M
BRET BAIER AND TONIGHT A
QUESTION FROM IMPEACHMENT DRAMA
DECADES PAST.
WHAT DID HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF
KNOW ABOUT THE INFAMOUS
WHISTLE-BLOWER REPORT THAT IS
FUELING TODAY'S IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY AND WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
WE LEARN TODAY SCHIFF WAS TIPPED
OFF DAYS BEFORE IT WAS FILED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CHARGES THAT
SCHIFF MAY HAVE HELPED WRITE IT.
ALSO PRESIDENT TRUMP RAMPING UP
ATTACKS ON SHIP SAYING HE MAY
HAVE COMMITTED TREASON.
HOWEVER DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
THREATENING SUBPOENAS FOR THE
PRESIDENTS TEAM AND THE
PRESIDENT IS BLAMING IMPEACHMENT
PEERS WITH A HUGE TEMPLE IN THE
STOCK MARKET TODAY.
HE IS ALSO COMPLAINING CONGRESS
IS WASTING TIME AND ENERGY WHAT
HE CONSIDERS AND WE WILL
ABBREVIATE, B.S.
FOX NEWS COVERAGE, ROBERT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AN ATTACK AND A SHIFT,
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA AND CHIEF
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE AND THE
REVELATION ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF,
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AND THE
TIMING OF IT ALL.
>> CONFIRMATION THAT
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND THE DEMOCRAT
CONTROLLED HOUSE COMMITTEE,
READING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
MOTIVATION AND POTENTIAL
POLITICAL BIAS.
>> IN A STATEMENT TO FOX NEWS
DEMOCRATIC CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF
SPOKESMAN CONFIRMED "THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER CONTACTED THE
COMMITTEE FOR GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
REPORT POSSIBLE WRONGDOING
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY."
THE QUESTIONS ON TIMING AND THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER CONTACT OCCURRED
DAYS OR WEEKS BEFORE THE
COMPLAINT WAS DECLASSIFIED.
ADDING "AT NO POINT DID THE
COMMUNITY -- COMMITTEE RECEIVE A
COMPLAINT IN ADVANCE."
HE DOESN'T KNOW IDENTITY OF
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND NOT MET WITH
OR SPOKEN WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER OR COUNCIL.
A PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED NEWS
CONFERENCE, THE PRESIDENT GOT
THE STORY AS IT BROKE AND
UNLOADED ON THE DEMOCRATIC
CHAIRMAN.
>> I GIVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
THE NEW YORK TIME TO PUT IT OUT.
IT HAPPENED AS I WALKED UP, HE
HANDED IT TO MAKE HIM A BIG
STORY.
HE KNEW LONG BEFORE.
IT IS A SCAM.
>> EARLIER IN THE DAY BEFORE THE
SCHIFF WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS KNOWN,
THE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE COMMITTEE
AND HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
SAID THE PRESIDENT'S OWN WORDS
ARE PROOF OF WRONGDOING.
THEY AGAIN POINTED TO THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL FOR THE
UKRAINIAN LEADER WHERE MR. TRUMP
ASKED ZIELINSKI TO ALLEGED
CORRUPTION WITH JOE BIDEN AND
HIS SON.
>> THE CONSTITUTION TO DO WHAT
HE DID AND HE ADMITTED TO ME,
NO, IT'S NOT PERFECT, IT IS
WRONG.
DEMOCRATS WITH MORE UKRAINE
RECORDS AND THE SCHIFF EXPECTS
BLOCKS.
>> WE WILL HAVE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO LITIGATE OR HOW TO
LITIGATE.
WE ARE NOT FOOLING AROUND HERE
THOUGH.
>> BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND
SECURE FACILITY, PETE MET THE
STAFFERS OFFERING WHAT WAS
CHARACTERIZED AS AN URGENT
BRIEFING ON UKRAINE.
ONE DEMOCRAT CURIOUS DOCUMENTS.
>> SIMPLY MEANT TO ADVANCE THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT MUELLER
IS FINDING.
AND IN THE ELECTION WAS
SPEECHLESS.
>> AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FORMER ENVOY TO UKRAINE, HE
RESIGNED AFTER THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT, A
TRANSCRIBED INTERVIEW WITH HOUSE
INVESTIGATORS.
REPUBLICANS ACCUSED DEMOCRATS OF
SEARCHING FOR A CRIME.
>> TRYING TO IMPEACH LITERALLY
THE DAY HE WAS ELECTED.
THEY KNOW THE TRANSCRIPT TO TIE
THE KNOT.
>> FOX NEWS ASKED
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S LEGAL TEAM IF
MULTIPLE AND THEY TOLD US THE
CLIENT OFFICIALLY FILED CONCERNS